officiellement l'heure et loire ne
compte que quatre zones blanches
mais dans les faits de nombreux secteurs
rencontrent des difficultés avec le
réseau téléphonique et internet
c'est pour établir la carte de ces zones
grises que le conseil départemental a
lancé il ya quelques jours une
consultation en ligne auprès d aurélien
et y'avait carte officielle mais aussi
la réalité la réalité du quotidien du
terrain et l'idée c'est que l'ensemble
des habitants puisse nous dire quelle
est la réalité qu'ils vivent eux l'idée
c'est que le territoire ne soit pas
délaissés et que l'on puisse faire
pression ensuite auprès du gouvernement
auprès des opérateurs pour que cette
annonce soit bien suivies d'effet
chapelle royale commune de 400 habitants
ne fait pas partie des zones blanches
reconnu par l'état
pourtant à côté de la mairie il s'avère
compliqué de passer un coup de fil
oui allô allô allô allô oui ça ne
fonctionne pas il y a quelques années
cette armoire haut débit a été installé
dans la commune
mais elle ne couvre qu'une petite partie
de chapelle royale pour son maire c'est
le manque d'intérêt des opérateurs qui
provoque l'isolément des communes
rurales
il faut absolument que on force les
opérateurs à investir et on doit les
obliger à investir à commencer par
investir par les eaux qui sont les moins
rentables parce qu'aujourd'hui ce sont
ces du commerce et les opérateurs
préfèrent investir dans des zones qui
sont rentables au détriment des zones
non rentables
quand vous êtes 350 habitants vous avez
un potentiel de clients très faible
cet isolement numérique ce sont avant
tout les entreprises de la commune qui
la ressentent pour avoir accès à
internet les ordinateurs de cette
société sont connectés par satellite
mais cela n'empêche pas les salariés de
rencontrer des difficultés nous on
travaille qu'avec internet sans internet
toute façon il ya plus on peut plus
travailler dans tous les domaines dans
tous les métiers on vous dit fait tout
par internet a oui mais quand vous avez
plus d'internet j'ai vu être une journée
sans pouvoir travailler
sauf que vous avez des délais aucun vous
devez faire quelque chose là vous faites
comment le conseil départemental a déjà
reçu près de mille réponses pour son
sondage en ligne les aurélien ont
jusqu'à la fin du mois de mars pour le
remplir les résultats seront connus en
oeuvre